[Music]
deforestation
is happening all around the world
approximately 15 billion trees are cut
down
every single year despite some forests
getting replanted if we keep going at
this rate
we'll have no trees in about 200 years
but what if that were to happen right
now
what would happen to our air quality
what would happen to animals
and do trees hold the key to our food
supply
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if all the world's trees were cut down
no more note taking no thank you cards
you'll never be able to put pen to paper
ever again but take a look at the bigger
picture
you'll have a lot more to worry about
than that when it comes to not having
any trees
one of your biggest worries might be the
air that we breathe
it's no secret that trees produce a lot
of our oxygen but
just how much well not as much as you
might think
through the magic of photosynthesis
trees produce roughly
half of the oxygen in our atmosphere we
have the oceans to thank for the other
half
with the ocean still intact we should
still be able to breathe but
it won't be what you're used to first
let's break down exactly how this might
be possible
well it's pretty far-fetched but in
order for us to cut down
all our trees we'd have to give everyone
on earth between the ages of 15 and 65
a chainsaw and ask them to cut down
about 625 trees each
if everyone on earth were on board with
this appalling assignment
we'd be finished this task in just under
a year
now what exactly would we do with all
these fallen trees on the ground
well we process quite a lot of them
continuing to make the various products
that we do today but
the vast majority of them would most
likely just lay on the ground and rot
and when they do over 35 billion yes
billion tons of carbon dioxide would be
released into the atmosphere
since trees release the gas when they
break down to put that in perspective
that's much more carbon dioxide than the
united states
canada and the uk produce in a single
year
it's a catastrophe that would most
likely kill our planet in short order
now it's not likely that the population
of earth is going to agree to chop down
every tree on the planet
so what if these trees all suddenly
disappeared
and we didn't have to cut them down
let's lighten this scenario up a bit and
start with a few good things that will
come with not having any trees
you can say goodbye to forest fires
every year forest fires around the world
burn down millions of acres of forest
destroy thousands of buildings and kill
hundreds of people
the largest ever forest fire in
california was responsible for
destroying over
18 000 buildings and cost the state and
insurers
over 16 billion dollars with no trees
people in places like california could
rest easy knowing their home is a bit
safer
sure fires could still happen with grass
and shrubs but firefighters say
these fires are much less dangerous and
easier to contain
and think of all the spare time you'll
have because of how much less yard work
you'll be dealing with
it's estimated that you're probably
raking half a million leaves every year
depending on the size of your yard this
could take upwards of a dozen
hours annually now you can use that time
for something
better but unfortunately you may have to
use it to figure out a way to survive
that's because you'd probably have
trouble breathing in this treeless world
an average tree produces enough oxygen
each year
for 10 people to breathe right now the
earth has trillions of trees producing
more than enough oxygen to sustain the
human population
but with all these trees gone you'd
quickly notice the world's air supply
diminishing
it'd be up to the ocean's phytoplankton
to provide our entire supply of o2
people would have a lot of trouble
breathing we wouldn't last too long
remember the world's population
increases over time
eventually the oxygen provided by the
oceans wouldn't be enough to sustain us
and if we continued to pollute the air
which let's be honest
we would the quality of the air we were
trying to breathe
would continue to degrade oxygen
wouldn't be the only thing we'd have
less of
it's pretty unlikely any new homes would
be built without any new trees
at least not the traditional houses that
we know today
a simple 110 square meter house requires
thousands of pieces of wood from the
basic frame to your walls and floors
and what about furniture no more chairs
tables desks the list goes on
houses in a world without trees would
look vastly different
sure there are other materials we could
use metal glass
mortar concrete but this would increase
costs significantly
and even today houses built with those
materials typically have some amount of
wood as well
not only that some of these materials
like glass
and concrete will probably cease to
exist one day
the world has a finite amount of sand
and we're quickly running out of it
too bad because sand is an essential
ingredient in making glass
and concrete now not to be too crass but
what to do about number two having no
paper
also means no toilet paper what will you
wipe with
the billions of pieces of toilet paper
we use every day
will be gone you won't be able to use
leaves as
those will be gone too instead you'll be
joining the 4 billion people around the
world who use
water to clean themselves after going to
the bathroom
but enough about that what about all the
other animals on the planet
according to the nature conservancy 50
of the world's plants and animals
live in the rainforest we're talking
about snakes
monkeys pandas elephants and whatever
else is lurking in there
and that 50 isn't even including all the
animals in the world's
other forests like deer rabbits and
thousands of bird species
without forests where would all these
animals live
unfortunately most of them would
probably cease to exist
just like with current deforestation
that kills millions of animals a year
and has made many of them extinct
evicted from their natural environment
it's unlikely that these animals would
be
able to adapt to someplace new in such a
short time
homeless predatory animals like bears
and wolves would probably be hunted
pretty quickly in order to keep humans
safe
and it's likely that the small number of
animals that would survive in this world
would be living much closer to humans as
scavenging may be their only way of
sourcing food
and it won't just be our furry woodland
creatures who are in trouble
it'll be bugs too insects depend on
vegetation for survival
they burrow into trees for shelter and
eat leaves for food
without these it's safe to say that
nearly all insects will become extinct
in fact it's already happening a 2019
study determined that
insect populations are decreasing by two
and a half percent
every year this is primarily due to
deforestation
and with every single tree removed from
earth you can expect the insect
population to diminish at a faster rate
than ever before
apart from keeping animals alive trees
also help immensely with
cleansing chemicals from the air the
leaves of trees
absorb various pollution particles from
the atmosphere
without trees you'd quickly notice a lot
more contaminants in the air
more pollution in the air means more
people dying
in 2015 six and a half million deaths
were linked to air pollution
one acre of trees absorbs roughly two
and a half tons of carbon dioxide every
year
without this absorption the negative
effects of climate change
increase significantly
expect the earth to get a lot hotter
trees help cool the planet in a number
of ways
not only do they provide shade but they
also release water through
photosynthesis
this helps cool areas down by several
degrees and provides rainfall
photosynthesis takes water from parts of
the tree and delivers it to the
atmosphere
the water goes into the clouds and
produces rain for the trees to absorb
once again
without this water cycle we'd see
reduced rainfall
researchers from humboldt university in
berlin estimate that if the amazon
rainforest were to lose all of its trees
rainfall there would decrease by 20
percent
this would bring on chronic droughts
across the globe causing lower water
levels in lakes and ponds
the droughts could get so bad as to
cause severe water shortages around the
world
leading to millions of deaths less rain
might sound like a good thing but
when it does rain expect massive storms
that could seriously affect the earth
dangerous mudslides and soil degradation
are all a serious possibility
what's that is your stomach grumbling
yeah
that'll happen a lot more without trees
think of all the food they provide
bananas coconuts apples the list goes on
and ah man no more maple syrup on your
pancakes
since it's made from sap drawn directly
from maple trees
things like chewing gum some candies
even some makeup will no longer exist
as they're derived from the wax of
carnauba palm trees
but that's not all in addition to
directly providing us with food
trees are also an essential part of all
other food production
that's because of the trees special
relationship with the soil
trees absorb a lot of the chemicals in
precipitation that would otherwise go
into our soil
not only that but trees also protect
soil from erosion by the rain
and they absorb water from the ground
when it gets too wet
we are predicting drought but when the
rare rains do come
they'll render the soil practically
useless with our soil degraded and full
of chemicals you can say goodbye to all
sorts of vegetation
from crops to grasses to plants
our world would quickly become a
desolate wasteland
not only would it look pretty ugly but
it would have a severe impact on the
agricultural industry
crops wouldn't grow and if they did
somehow manage to sprout
they'd be too unhealthy for us to eat
not to mention without insects like bees
and butterflies to pollinate our crops
we'd have an even more difficult time
growing anything no more vegetables
fruits breads or nearly any other type
of food that you enjoy daily
so if the poor air quality doesn't kill
humans the food shortage probably would
this has been pretty traumatic hasn't it
no more food
animals and eventually no more humans
we should probably console each other
over a nice warm campfire
wait we won't be able to do that either
okay
maybe being a tree hugger isn't so bad
although we could kiss forest fires and
leaf raking goodbye would it
really be worth it definitely not
hopefully we never have to worry about
this as long as we keep planting our
trees
saying no to deforestation and most
importantly
continuing to watch what if